[Musique]
nous sommes de retour à san francisco et
nous savons où chercher la chorale
un peu à l'écart du centre ville au
coeur du quartier homosexuels dans un
très vieux cinéma le castro
nous débarquons en pleine répétition
[Musique]
nous avons bien choisi notre jour
la chorale fait aujourd'hui sa 32e année
d'existence
dom birch choriste depuis les années 80
vient rappeler à ses camarades les
années terribles que furent les années
sida
la chorale a traversé des moments
vraiment terrible vous savez un moment
nous n'étions plus que 85 chanteur trois
d'entre nous étaient morts la même
semaine
vous connaissez je vais me remettre à
pleurer voilà pourquoi nous devons
préserver notre esprit de famille c'est
très important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
le
au bout de 32 ans d'existence nous avons
plus de chanteur décédé que de chanteur
vivant il ne faut pas l'oublier
à chaque fois que l'un d'entre nous
monte sur scène ils représentent deux
personnes lui même et un autre chanteur
qui n'a plus la chance d'être là la
chorale compte aujourd'hui 230 chanteur
mais parmi les choristes nous ne
reconnaissons aucun des visages que nous
avions croisé il ya 18 ans ni celui de
gary
ni celui de scott
tous deux disparus emportés par la
maladie
en revanche nous reconnaissons cette
chanson
à
[Musique]
e
oh
elle nous rappelle un autre des
choristes que nous avions croisé à
l'époque
oh
[Musique]
jim d'higgins entonné lui aussi over the
rainbow chant de ralliement de la
communauté gay et nous vous avions
raconté son histoire
[Musique]
jim avait eu un fils d'un premier
mariage puis il avait découvert son
homosexualité et partager la vie de
robert
au moment de notre premier reportage il
ya 18 ans robert venait de mourir du
sida et la chorale était rassemblée pour
célébrer ses obsèques
[Musique]
la seule chose à laquelle robert ne
m'avait pas préparé c'est à l'énorme
soutien les normes amour que j'ai reçu
ces deux dernières semaines
à ces deux derniers mois ces deux
dernières années de chacun d'entre nous
pour retrouver jean d'higgins nous avons
dû quitter san francisco et faire 800
kilomètres jusqu'à san diego jim habite
désormais dans ce petit pavillon seul
avec ses souvenirs
après la mort de son compagnon il a bien
eu quelques aventures mais il n'a jamais
refait sa vie
chez lui les étagères sont couvertes de
photos de son fils et de son amant
disparu aujourd'hui pour la première
fois il revoit les images que nous
avions tourné à l'époque
oh
[Musique]
non
ça fait remonter beaucoup d'émotion ces
visages que je n'ai pas revu depuis
longtemps
[Musique]
c'était une famille une vraie famille
c'était des gens qui étaient ensemble
parce qu'il le souhaitait pas parce
qu'il y était obligé
jim a quitté san francisco et la chorale
bouleversé usé par les décès de son
amant et de beaucoup de ses amis dans
les années 90 aujourd'hui il se
considère comme un rescapé
[Musique]
robert et moi adorions la comédie
musicale les misérables
il ya cette chanson intitulée les
chaises vides et les tables vides elle
dit avant nous venons ici passer de bons
moments avec nos amis maintenant je suis
seul mes amis ont disparu et c'est cela
que je ressens le sentiment de
culpabilité du survivant
c'est probablement pour ça que j'ai fini
par m'en fuir c'était trop dur ça
c'était la bac de fin d'études que
porter robert je lui ai dit juste avant
qu'il ne meure je ne veux qu'une seule
chose de toi c'est ta bague il n'a plus
jamais quitté ma main jim d'higgins
définitivement lié à son amant à la
chorale
aux etats unis l'épidémie de sida a tué
plus d'un demi million de personnes
à san francisco un mémorial rassemble
des centaines de noms de victimes
tom rencontré à l'anniversaire de la
chorale entretien ici le souvenir de
nombreux amis aelia steve brian donc
frasier
peter brockhoff lui aussi d'états
membres de la chorale
ces gens sont morts
et moi j'ai survécu aïe je me sens
l'obligation d'honorer leur mémoire
parce que c'étaient des gens bien
à 63 ans tom est l'un des rares
choristes qui est connu les chanteurs
que nous avions filmé en 1992 il a gardé
un souvenir particulier de l'un d'entre
eux gary falardeau et sa voix claire et
joyeuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet ancien danseur souffrait d'une
maladie osseuse qui peu à peu gagné
toutes les parties de son corps
tous ces rêves avait été brisée par le
sida je voulais devenir une star je
voulais être un acteur et un chanteur
devenir célèbre et n'est pas arrivé
alors aujourd'hui la chorale ça fait du
bien à mon ego si je veux survivre à
m'adapter à ce que subit mon corps
malgré la douleur gary falardeau a
toujours accompagné la chorale en
tournée même lorsque ses jambes ne
pouvait plus le porter je sens que très
bientôt je vais les rejoindre et ils le
savent je sens qu'il me regarde et qu'il
m'appelle gary allez viens c'est bientôt
l'heure
ce que je ressens c'est comme un appel à
retrouver les autres de toute façon tout
sera mieux que ce que de continuer comme
ça avec la douleur tout le temps
c'est leurs pendants
[Musique]
trop de douleur
ça
[Musique]
oh
gary à accepter son destin et il a
continué d'avancer
nous savions qu'il souffrait
terriblement
nous savions que sa vie n'était plus la
même paul et m mais ça ne l'a pas vaincu
il est resté lui même jusqu'au 8
condamnée gary avait décidé de se porter
volontaires pour des essais
thérapeutiques cobayes humains dans
l'espoir qu'un jour après lui la maladie
serait vaincu mon point de vue c'est que
si nous ne le faisons pas qu'il fera le
gouvernement s'en moquent totalement
alors il faut que les gens comme moi
prennent ces pilules et permettent aux
essais thérapeutiques de progresser cela
pour que cette maladie ne tue pas tout
le monde que lorsque mon heure viendra
les gens se disent que j'ai fait quelque
chose de positif dans ma vie et sur ce
monde
d'autres comme un mort ne sera pas
complètement oublié comme si je n'avais
jamais existé mais ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'on se souvienne de moi
lorsqu'ils ont appris que nous étions
revenus les films et dix huit ans après
de nombreux membres de la chorale ont
insisté pour voir le reportage réalisé
en 1992 et leurs souvenirs ont refait
surface
ça me fout le moral à zéro de me dire
que j'ai perdu des dizaines de bons amis
à l'époque les gens qui chantaient avec
nous dans la chorale ont tous disparu je
me souviens que j'allais dans les
hôpitaux je suis notaire et pour ses
jeux recueilli leurs dernières volontés
1 il fallait qu'ils fassent leur
testament pour eux pour leurs familles
est souvent par déni il refusait de se
préparer à ça et pour moi c'était une
bénédiction de pouvoir aider ces malades
ces familles affronter leurs peurs mais
les plus jeunes ceux qui n'ont pas connu
les années 90 quel regard porte-t-il sur
cette époque le débat s'installe le
problème des jeunes homosexuels c'est
que beaucoup d'entre eux pensent que
tout ça c'est du passé je pense que
maintenant les gens vivent avec le sida
et que finalement ils ne sont pas
vraiment en danger dans mon cercle
d'amis les gens que je connais à san
francisco tout le monde est séropositif
à part moi et certains sont très mal
ça montre bien qu'il ya un vrai problème
parce que notre génération à l'époque
elle n'était pas au courant
votre génération elle s'est enfin moi
expérience personnelle oblige je n'aime
pas trop qu'on veuille donner des leçons
de morale aux jeunes parce que c'est
exactement ce qui se passait chez moi je
ne fais pas de leçons de morale je dis
juste qu'il ya un problème
aujourd'hui l'histoire de ses copains
mais enfin pourquoi pourquoi comment
est-ce qu'on peut attraper le sida
aujourd'hui alors qu'on est en forme et
moi je ne comprends pas je ne comprends
pas pourquoi les jeunes ne prennent pas
le sida au sérieux mais qu'est ce qui te
fait dire qu il
le prennent pas au sérieux mais parce qu
ils l'attrapent rems à 37 ans il vit
avec le sida depuis 17 ans il fait
partie de cette génération qui a vu
arriver les premières trithérapie en
1996 et c'est grâce à cela qu'il a
survécu
[Musique]
il a attrapé le virus lorsqu'il était
encore étudiant à l'université et il
reconnaît qu'il aurait pu l'éviter
[Musique]
les campagnes de prévention existait
bien à l'époque mais je n'y prêtais pas
attention
j'étais à la fac c'était une période
d'abandon d'insouciance la sonnette
d'alarmé avait déjà été tiré mais je ne
l'entendais pas en tout cas pas assez je
n'avais encore dit à personne que
j'étais homosexuel à l'époque
en fait j'ai pressé toute ma vie
d'homosexuel en tant que séropositifs
james mène aujourd'hui une vie presque
normale grâce à une impressionnante
batterie de médicaments antirétroviraux
c'est ce qu'on appelle le cocktail et il
faut y ajouter des vitamines et des
antidépresseurs
le traitement permet de ralentir la
multiplication du virus et renforce son
système immunitaire
je ne prend pas ses médicaments pour ne
pas mourir je les prends pour vivre
mieux
le sida n'est plus synonyme de peine de
mort comme c'était le cas il ya quelques
années
c'est une maladie mortelle mais
contrôlable
mais attention cela ne veut surtout pas
dire que c'est facile de vivre avec
je dois en permanence m'occuper de mon
corps je dois bien manger je dois faire
du sport prendre mes médicaments garder
un cercle d'amis qui s'occupent de moi
qui mêle est aussitôt que je me laisse
aller que je ne m'occupe pas
quotidiennement ma santé je re donne aux
virus l'occasion de refaire surface
l'année dernière james a été un peu
négligents avec son traitement
il a développé une forme rare de
méningite salut jim cette visite chez
son médecin intervient après un long
séjour à l'hôpital
je vais commencer par écouter tes
poumons et ton coeur respire
profondément
des analyses sont bonnes et le virus est
indétectable dans le sait bien ces
chiffres me confirme que tu prends bien
tout et médicaments donc il n'ya pas de
quoi s'inquiéter
ça me rassure ce que tu viens certains
me disent que ce n'est pas qu'une
histoire de chiffres mais ça compte
vraiment pas je suis un homosexuel qui
est devenue médecin pendant la crise du
sida
quand personne ne comprenait ce qui se
passait énerve et maintenant à guetter
terre je peux enfin dire à mes patients
que s'il n'oublie pas de prendre leurs
médicaments
ils ont de grandes chances d'atteindre
une espérance de vie quasi normale
et ça c'est vraiment incroyable
[Musique]
point
m
[Musique]
avant
les trithérapies en 1992 ça n'existait
pas encore
chaque jour scott galut thérias injecter
des potions aux plantes de l'homéopathie
contre le virus
beaucoup de naïveté je ne veux pas que
mon corps devienne un champ de bataille
je veux qu'il soit un lieu de paix et
d'amour je veux que le virus se sentent
tellement à l'aise dans mon corps que
doucement s'assoupissent et peu à peu
s'endorment complètement au phare
[Musique]
le virus ne s'est pas endormi scott
galut teria a déclaré le sida quelques
mois après ces images il est mort deux
ans après une génération sépare scott
james
en vingt ans les victimes du sida sont
devenus beaucoup plus rare et cela a
changé la chorale des deuils nous en
avons connu beaucoup mais ces dernières
années à la chorale
nous n'avons eu que deux enterrements ça
ne veut pas dire que l'esprit de famille
n'est plus là les chanteurs ne meurent
plus ça non il fonde ma faveur
il est vrai que dans les années 80
lorsque la communauté homosexuelle de
san francisco descendez dans la rue
c'était pour protester contre le manque
de moyens contre l'indifférence de
l'administration américaine face à
l'hécatombe sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville
la foule scandait les noms des victimes
un cri de détresse collectif qui pendant
des années n'a pas été entendu
2009 la même foule au même endroit mais
pour d'autres raisons
ce jour là la communauté homosexuelle
protestent contre le résultat d'un
référendum qui a mis fin au droit au
mariage pour les gays un droit acquis
seulement quelques mois plus tôt
[Musique]
yann jouvenot fait partie de cette
nouvelle génération de choristes il est
français il s'est installé aux états
unis il y a dix ans pour le travail et
il n'est jamais reparti il s'est
toujours protéger contre le sida
[Musique]
il s'est marié et a adopté deux garçons
âgés aujourd'hui de 2 3 1 le mariage
maintenant est devenu le la dernière
frontière je dirais pas cessé c'est le
dernier acquis pour pouvoir vraiment
dire bon bah écoute et voilà on est des
personnes à part entière on fait partie
de la société comme tout le monde on
paie nos impôts on a des enfants les
gens vont à l'école on est des bons
voisins des bons parents des bons amis
alors pourquoi ne pas être traités de
façon égale
[Musique]
yann habite dans une petite maison de la
banlieue de san francisco et ce soir la
famille a les yeux rivés sur la
télévision un référendum sur le mariage
homosexuel a lieu ce jour là il ne
concerne que l'état du maine
mais yann se sent directement concerné
si le mail vote oui cela pourrait
entraîner beaucoup d'autres états dans
le pays
ça au moins ça va être vraiment énorme
parce que c'est la première fois en fait
que le mariage homosexuel a été approuvé
par vote populaire quoi avant c'était
toujours la législature où les juges
s'assurent la cour suprême de chaque
état si ça passe c'est vraiment
historique
[Musique]
plus tard dans la soirée
le résultat du référendum tombe et c'est
une douche froide
le chemin va être long c'est vrai qu'on
n'est plus dans les années 70 ou 80 où
on pouvait être éjectée de son
appartement parce qu'on était homo on
pouvait être virer de son boulot tout
simplement parce qu'on était homo est
certainement est loin des années ou même
les infirmières ne voulez pas vous
toucher parce que j'ai une maladie cpt
les gens ne connaissaient pas mais mais
on n'est pas encore les homos continuer
à ne pas pouvoir donner du sens parce
que le chant mot sexuelle ne peut pas ne
peut pas être mélangés à la populace
même si on a des tests contre le hiv
très très sûr mais encore du chemin à
faire mais encore du chemin à faire
le lendemain soir nous retrouvons tous
les choristes réunis pour la fête de
thanksgiving
c'est le vétéran de la chorale tom burke
qui a créé ce rendez vous il ya 22 ans
pour réconforter les choristes malades
ceux qui étaient rejetés par leur
famille aujourd'hui il mesure le chemin
parcouru
de plus en plus de familles accepte
l'homosexualité de leur enfant ou leur
séropositivité
heureusement pour les homos le monde a
changé pendant ses vingt ans en mieux
mais c'est toujours bien de garder les
traditions et cette soirée est une bonne
tradition pour la chorale ce soir
l'occasion était trop belle
nous avons demandé à jean d'higgins de
revenir à san francisco et de rendre
visite à ses anciens camarades
[Musique]
il ne les a pas revus depuis 18 ans
et ça fait du bien de te revoir
tu as l'air très en forme t'as pas l'air
si vieux que ça et toi non plus tu as
pas pris une ride
[Musique]
en fait j'ai un sentiment partagé
c'est formidable de retrouver tous ces
gens que j'ai connus il ya longtemps et
en même temps c'est bizarre car il ya
aussi tellement de gens que je ne
connais pas la chorale a beaucoup changé
mais j'ai le sentiment que tout continue
la même camaraderie la même énergie la
même fraternité c'est bien de voir que
tout ça est toujours vivant
la dernière séquence de notre reportage
en 1992 est resté gravé dans notre
mémoire nous avions filmé jim sur cette
plage non loin du golden gate
il est temps pour moi de dire au revoir
complètement de laisser aller à
disperser ces cendres samoa
[Musique]
sur cette même plage le lendemain de la
fête de thanksgiving
avant qu'il ne rentre chez lui nous
avons retrouvé jim
il
oh
[Musique]
c'est est ici que je devais le faire
pour garder un lien je me suis toujours
dit que je répandrai ses cendres ici et
qu'elle se mélangeraient avec le sable
est emporté par la mer elle tirait sur
toutes les plages où je suis
depuis plus de trente ans les hommes de
san francisco chante beaucoup ne sont
plus là mais leurs voix sont plus fortes
que jamais
[Musique]
à